[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i would like to begin by thanking our
generous donors especially the logan
family
without them this event would not be
possible and on behalf of both myself
and our ave maria university community
i cannot thank them enough for their
generosity secondly i would like to
thank all of you here tonight for your
interest in young americans for freedom
this is our chapter's first semester and
we're thrilled to have the enthusiasm
for the club that we do
our chapter has weekly meetings tuesday
nights at 7 p.m
in the hub where members discuss current
political events and issues
our chapter has also attended yf
conferences throughout the country which
can be paid for
in full by yaf for further involvement
with our chapter here at ave maria
please see our tables out in front to
join our email list to stay up to date
about upcoming events
without further ado i would like to
introduce our speaker for tonight
from selling tens of thousands of copies
of a literally
blank book to affecting clay aiken's
most public meltdown
of the decade michael knowles is a man
who really needs no introduction
michael swift rise from screen and stage
actor
to one of america's most beloved
conservative voices
can be traced to his unwavering belief
in the ideals that make america great
his rock solid faith in the god of the
bible and his steadfast commitment
to seeking truth beauty and goodness
michael is the shark topping host of
both the michael knull show at the daily
wire
and the book club at prageru michael
also co-hosts
verdict with ted cruz which he and the
senator co-piloted
to the number one podcast in the world
with their signature interviews
analysis into it thanks to his stinging
sense of humor
michael's most recent book reasons to
vote for democrats
was touted by by president trump as a
great book
for your reading enjoyment seriously it
became number one in the world
michael's ability to present ideas in
light of the first principles that
undergird them has propelled him to
become
one of the most requested conservative
lecturers in the country
in fact michael's events are so popular
that we are joined tonight
live online by tens of thousands of his
fans
from around the world michael a yale
literature graduate
is frequently published on quoted by and
featured across conservative media
if america has an intelligentsia today
michael knowles is
certainly a part of it without further
delay
it is my pleasure to introduce the
dapper
lip triggering troll himself mr michael
[Music]
knowles
very kind of you wow thanks everybody
wow oh man
all right thank you so much
14 months 14 months it's been since i've
been on a college campus
with any of you it is so good to be with
all of you right now
my goodness last year we were supposed
to do 20 of those
i was going to get to come down there
and people cheering and we talk about
conservative things
and how terrible the left is we were
going to do that 20 times
and then they got rid of it they locked
down
i think they were afraid of the speaking
tour i don't i think the virus was an
excuse
we had to slow the spread we had to
flatten the curve
we had to find a cure we have double
triple mutant variants now so we got to
do it all over again
whatever the experts are spouting this
week thank you
of course to ave maria for having me
thank you to yaff for hosting
thank you to the logan family as always
for sponsoring this lecture series
it's so great to be here at ave maria
especially during easter week
we've got a lot of catholic students a
catholic school
i'm a catholic speaker but we're not
thankful let's go we can applaud for now
we can
you know why i sense i sensed the
reticence i said wait
there's going to be a but he's there's
going to be a butt here and there is
all those wonderful catholic things we
will not be talking about catholicism
tonight
i want to talk about a different
religion
i want to talk about the religion
of secular progressivism our state
church
which shut down our country this year i
want to talk about that church of
progressivism and i want to talk about
its high priest
dr anthony fauci the exalted dr fauci
peace be upon him
is the present pontiff in our state
church of progressivism
he presides over its rituals his
proclamations
are deemed to be absolutely
infallible he even wears a funny robe
he does dr fauci wears a white lab coat
instead of the pectoral cross he wears a
stethoscope
that is his cassock that is his symbol
but substantive beliefs
aside the only formal difference that i
see between dr fauci and the pope
is that dr fauci has much more power you
see
the the pope speaks infallibly when he
speaks
ex-cathedra on on matters of doctrine
concerning faith and morals
dr fauci is said to be infallible
about everything about anything he says
even when his infallible proclamations
contradict
his previous infallible proclamations it
doesn't matter
whatever he said most recently that is
infallible dr fauci demonstrated his
grip on church and state last march
when he told everyone to stop wearing
masks do you remember this
because i have the quote i don't want to
be taken off of youtube i have the quote
here from dr fauci he says
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better
it might even block a droplet but it is
not providing the perfect protection
that people think it is
but dr fauci did not just leave it there
he didn't just
say that the masks were ineffective he
actually went further
there are unintended consequences people
keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
according to dr fauci not only did the
masks not help
they actually actively harmed the public
health
then a few weeks later everything
changed you remember this dr fauci
decided
that not only are masks effective at
slowing the spread
actually they're essential he insisted
on
quote universal wearing of masks
so what changed was it the science that
changed
the science no it was not the science
even even dr fauci admitted that
he said all right one more time
back then there was the critical issue
to save
masks for the people who really needed
them because it was felt
it was felt not i felt it was felt by
some
that there was a shortage of masks in
other words
dr fauci believed that the masks would
protect people
but he considered some people more
deserving of the masks than other people
so he lied to the public and told them
that the masks would not protect anybody
so that there would be more masks left
over for his fellow public health
workers
the decision as he admitted his own
words
was not primarily scientific the
decision was primarily political
but dr fauci couldn't quite admit that
during an interview on the daily show
with trevor noah you missed it so did
everybody else
he dr fauci was asked about this flip
and he said i'm not going to do the fact
you voice anymore i'll get a sore throat
if i keep doing it.
all right one more time he says he says
for goodness sakes i've never had a
political ideology that i've made public
i'm really just talking to you about
public health
when i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing
avoid crowds wash your hands
do things outdoors more than indoors
there's nothing political about that
that's a public health message that we
know
works now i will give
dr fauci the benefit of the doubt and i
will chalk this ridiculous statement
up to ignorance but he actually claimed
that his decision to reorder the way
that 330 million people
live work relax
travel walk out the front door
that his decision to mandate how people
would open their businesses or not open
their businesses
was not political shut down the economy
curtail constitutional rights
close churches but don't close marijuana
dispensaries those are essential
all of that was not political according
to dr fauci because dr fasch he didn't
care about politics you see
he just cares about what works
do you see the problem here i bet that
everyone in this room sees the problem
because this is a good catholic
university and you all have very good
philosophical education
in order for something to work it needs
to have a purpose
a lawn mower works when it cuts grass
a lock a key rather works when it opens
up
a lock to determine whether or not
something works you need to know what
that thing
is for you need to know what you're
aiming at
under the old constitutional system of
government we the people determined
what we would like society to work
toward
within the confines of constitutional
government
that old system rested on a christian
worldview madison described
this vision in the federalist papers he
said that this that government is the
greatest reflection on human nature
he wrote in federalist 51 if men were
angels
no government would be necessary if
angels were to govern men
neither external nor internal controls
on government would be necessary
in framing a government which is to be
administered by men
over men the great difficulty lies in
this you must first enable the
government
to control the governed and in the next
place
oblige it to control itself when our
most
consciously progressive president
woodrow wilson entered office he enters
office
in 1913. he says enough of that
enough of that according to wilson the
old constitutional government
that was created back when we were
living under the laws of isaac newton
you know fixed permanent nature uh
forces that need to be balanced against
one another uh
forces that require a system of checks
and balances and a separation of powers
now wilson believed we've disproved all
of that
that's all over we're living in the age
of darwin where everything's constantly
evolving
and therefore we need to ditch the old
constitutional order and empower
scientific experts
unaccountable to the people on the
country for us because the ex
know what works
dr fauci is not the only prelate in the
church of progressivity
has deputies deputy signed to guide
is my microphone cutting is is you
finally clamping down they're saying no
michael 14 months wasn't long enough
your work's shutting you down now
it's too i can't even yell because i did
my fouchy impression too much so
my voice is totally gone dr
fauci has deputies one such deputy is
dr rachel levine dr rachel levine is our
nation's current assistant secretary of
health
for 54 years dr rachel was known as dr
richard
until in 2011 dr rachel decided
that he would pretend to be a woman in
his public life
now he is the assistant secretary of
health in the united states
dr levine has not only embraced
transgender ideology as a matter of
personal preference for adults
dr levine has publicly advocated pumping
little children full of cross-sex
hormones
so that little johnny can look more like
little jane
now according to biology rachel levine
is a man
according to progressivism rachel levine
is whatever he wants to be
because in order for mankind to become
truly liberated according to this
ideology
we must throw off not merely the chains
of social convention
but even the shackles of nature and this
radical self-definition this central
mystery
and sacrament of the secular progressive
faith
cannot be left up to the whims and
opinions
of free people it's got to go to the
experts
rachel levine said i don't think
this is a political issue at all this is
about
fairness and equality and about
specifically health
equity how is equality different than
health equity i don't know
but you'll notice what he said here what
levine said it's the same thing dr fauci
said
this isn't about politics the idea that
we're going to have a policy to pump all
your kids full of cross-sector
that's not political what are you
talking about what did he mean he
obviously didn't mean
that laws and policies are not political
by definition those things are political
what he meant is that the decision over
whether or not to chemically castrate
children is no longer up for political
debate
it is not a matter that we the people
have any right to weigh in on
it is a matter of science and therefore
the scientists
have to make the decision for us and if
the scientists determine that little
boys should be made to look like little
girls
well then we just have to go along with
that that is what progress
demands the proselytizers of
progressivism justify their authority
by appealing to science which they
insist is a more objective
and reliable means of ordering society
than say i don't know
philosophy or religion you see
philosophy and religion those are just
values
those are just preferences you know you
got yours right you got your religion
you got your philosophy and i got mine
and we can never
make any sense of it science they say
gives us something sturdy to rely on
but the left does not actually deliver
less religion in politics
they just order their politics according
to a different religion
transgenderism at its most basic level
is nothing more than the ancient heresy
of gnostic dualism
this is an old heresy that posits that
the body and soul are
totally separate and the body has
nothing to do with who we really are
so i might i might look like a man you
can see i've got an adam's apple
i've got various other appendages that
this is going to be a g-rated lecture so
we won't get into it
but you can take my word for it i appear
in every way physically
to be a man but if i say that on some
deeper metaphysical level
with some secret knowledge that i have
that i am a woman
then i am a woman according to this
faith
it's not complicated it's not like i'm
half and half or i'm
three quarters of this it's not
complicated at all i simply
am a woman according to this philosophy
so on the one hand the left pushes the
gnostic religion of transgenderism as
the
undeniable scientific account of human
nature
then on the other hand those very same
leftists tell us
that our bodies have everything to do
with who we are
they will tell us that we are nothing
more than our bodies
do you ever hear there's this very
overrated writer who who white liberals
love his name is tom
heezy and he he exclusively refers to
black
bodies he doesn't refer to black people
he seems to suggest that black people
don't have souls
because he only refers to their bodies
and i don't think it's because he
believes black people don't have souls i
think it's because
he doesn't think any of us have souls i
think it's because he thinks that we are
all
just material first they peddle
gnostic dualism in the next breath they
peddle
scientific materialism this idea that
we're all just walking
talking meat puppets we're all all of
our hopes all of our dreams all of our
fears
all of the immaterial things that matter
most in our lives
it's all just fake it's all delusions
caused by
electricity firing off in our brains so
which is it
which of the two is it are we flee f
free-floating spirits
that are that are trapped inside bodies
that really we should not be trapped
inside
or is the spirit an illusion
are we all just bodies that are going to
turn to worm food someday
the left alternates between these two
theories according to political
convenience
so for instance when they advocate for
gay rights
they go the materialist route you see
our sexual desires can't change
we are just our bodies people should
never interfere with nature or natural
inclinations
then when the left pushes transgenderism
they go the gnostic route they say
we're not our bodies everything is
socially constructed forget about sexual
desire sex itself
is socially constructed we must mutilate
our bodies
if nature is somehow impeding our
desires
totally conflicting visions of the world
somehow both of those religious visions
are scientific
and incontrovertible the only view that
you are not allowed to hold is the
correct view
this is the traditional christian
understanding of human nature
even before the advent of of
christianity this was the view held by
old uncle aristotle this is the idea
that human beings are the union of body
and soul
an inextricable union so long as we're
walking around this earth
the technical term for this view is
hylomorphism
and i know all of you with your
excellent philosophical education
already know that
for anyone else who's watching online if
you want to sound smart at parties
that's a great word to do it
hylomorphism wow
man that's a smart word that view is not
allowed
that view is considered it's religious
it's philosophical it's
not scientific the french poet charles
borlaire
famously observed that the devil's
finest trick is to persuade you that he
doesn't exist
the same might be said of secular
progressives their finest trick
is to convince you that their religion
is not religious
they say that we need less religion in
politics
meaning less of our religion and
politics and
unfortunately they've gotten a number of
self-styled conservatives to go along
with this idea
did anybody watch the governor of
arkansas's appearance on tucker the
other night
did you see that in this i'm sorry that
you had to watch that it's kind of
kind of delicious to watch uh tucker eat
this man for dinner you know
the the for those who didn't catch it
the republican governor of arkansas
had just vetoed a bill that would
prevent perverts from pumping little
kids full of cross-sex hormones
and he went on tucker carlson's show to
defend this decision
as conservative he said that the bill
protecting children from this insane
secular religion
was just a product of the cultural war
in america
and so his response you see to this
cultural war in america
was to completely concede and to give
the left everything
that's how he was going to deal with it
governor hutchinson i kid you not
invoked william f buckley jr and
ronald reagan in his attempt to recast
castrating little kids as conservative
he appealed to limited government i do
not want to presume to speak for the
dead
okay i didn't know ronald reagan i never
even got the chance to meet buckley
however
i don't think castrating children was a
part of their political vision i don't
know i've read them
for a long time watched a lot of their
videos
i love limited government limited
government is a fine thing
if protecting children from gelding does
not fall within those limits
what does nothing would now governor asa
hutchinson does not want to talk about
cultural issues you see
he wants to focus on much more important
issues
like the marginal corporate tax rate
yeah oh man
that gets our blood pumping doesn't it
you see
cultural issues such as oh i don't know
the definition of marriage
family killing babies in the womb how we
educate
kids how we educate the whole country
whether little girls need to change
in front of men at the public pool what
we're allowed to say at school what
we're allowed to say at work
all those that doesn't matter that's a
product of the cultural war according to
governor hutchinson
who even cares about those things if i'm
waking up in the middle of the night
in a cold sweat it's going to be about
occupational licensing reform i think
you know
it is oh gosh a shudder even to think of
it
i have only one question for governor
hutchinson and for those
who agree with him if cultural issues
don't matter
why does the left seem to care so much
about them have you noticed
how much time and energy they spent
obviously the left
is the aggressor in the culture war
their problem is the way things are they
don't like the way things are and so
they spend a lot of time and money
trying to upend them if cultural issues
don't matter why is the left so
convinced
that they do in reality cultural issues
are the only issues that matter all
political issues are cultural
and all cultural issues ultimately are
religious
cardinal manning put this very well he
said that all human conflict ultimately
is theological but the squishes don't
like that
they don't want to hear that they tell
us i'm sure you've heard this before
they tell us you can't legislate
morality
and they're almost right the only
problem with that is that
it's the opposite of true you
necessarily
legislate morality all laws
capital punishment abortion down to
speeding tickets
all laws refer to the moral law to the
you're making moral arguments for these
things
this cowardice this reticence to assert
any substantive
moral or political vision is the great
trap
of political correctness or wokism or
cancel culture use whatever term you
want
one of the tricks of political
correctness is it changes all the terms
so the term itself changes a lot i
discussed this trap at great length in
my upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
which is for now available for pre-order
i assume
look if if they're already tinkering
with our video stream right now there's
no way that book lasts on amazon but
anyway it's available now you can
pre-order it the book advance is what i
call
the admiral akbar thesis it's a trap
political correctness lays a trap for
conservatives
whereby just about any way that we react
to it
actually furthers political correctness
what i mean by this is political
correctness
is a purely negative campaign that is
designed to destroy
traditional standards the leftist
intellectuals who developed pc were
explicit about this
they set out in marx's words on the
ruthless criticism of
all that exists from this you see
intellectual movements such as critical
theory
most recently you've heard a lot about
critical race theory which is a
derivation of critical theory
now when you get past all of the very
pretentious jargon
involved in critical theory the theory
is very simple
the theory is to criticize it's very
easy anybody can do it
the purpose is to criticize and
ultimately destroy
traditional standards so conservatives
react
in one of two ways the squishes give in
this goes without saying they say oh
it's not a big deal
it's only culture so what if we castrate
a few kids you know
let's just go along to get along
obviously that
advances political correctness but the
other group of conservatives that
obstinate group that does not want to
give in to pc's new standards and all
the speech codes and all that
they react in a way that is just as
damaging
they often disavow standards altogether
they will say that they support free
speech
absolutism or academic freedom
or some other abstract concept like that
totally divorced
from the actual free speech tradition
and the actual educational tradition
in the united states william f buckley
jr
who to correct governor hutchinson did
not want to pump the kids full of
hormones william f buckley jr
in whose living room this organization
was founded
understood the difference now we hear
all this talk even from people who
apparently seem to like buckley but
absolute free speech
ism this ism and that is academic
freedom is so great
the very title of william f buckley jr's
first book god and man at yale this is
the book that's credited with launching
the post-war conservative movement
the subtitle of that book is the
superstitions
of academic freedom in the book he calls
academic freedom a hoax
which it is it is a hoax after god and
man at yale
bill buckley wrote an entire book
defending joe mccarthy
a dozen years later bill buckley was
still defending mccarthyism on tv
as well he should have the founding
fathers established one of the freest
speech regimes in the world
and it was precisely to protect that
free speech tradition
that they outlawed broad swaths of
speech
fraud sedition threats obscenity
other categories too until very recently
conservatives had standards
over the last couple of decades
conservatives have thrown standards out
the window
because they mistakenly believe that
political correctness is a battle
between free speech
and censorship when in fact it is a
battle between competing
sets of standards the traditional
standards by which america flourished
and the anti-standard standards of pc
that sets out to destroy our country
there have been prominent voices on the
right over the past few years
who have defended drag queen story hour
they i kid you not they have defended
drag queen story hour
as one of the blessings of liberty
not sure james madison had that in mind
exactly
you can hear the founding fathers
rolling in their graves at that very
statement
these misguided conservatives argue that
we can't go around making moral
judgments
because you see if we tell perverts that
they can't twerk for toddlers at the
public library
why then they might tell us we can't go
to church on sunday
never mind by the way that they are
already telling us we can't go to church
on sunday
and they have for a year now never mind
that no we need to pretend that
everything is the same
and everything is neutral these guys
think that it is somehow illegitimate
for conservatives to articulate a moral
and political vision
they believe that that sort of thing
would make us no different from the left
well you see if i tell you not to twerk
for kids then you know you might tell me
this and it's all that isn't
good and good is bad and right is wrong
and up is down and east is west and
right no i don't think so
the problem with this theory of course
is
not only that it is contradicted by
history the founding fathers and every
single conservative until about five
minutes ago
all asserted substantive visions of
politics
but the other problem here is that this
argument undermines
self-government if these guys are right
and we really cannot distinguish between
right and wrong good and bad
true and false then we cannot govern
ourselves
we do not possess the capacity for
self-government
which relies on that ability of
discernment
the whole premise of self-government is
that we the people possess reason and
moral conscience
which is a judgment of reason and we can
use those things with due humility
and with deference to tradition to craft
our own political order
within the bounds set by the
constitution
this conception of self-government has a
long history in our culture
it is rooted ultimately in our religion
which holds that our creator endowed us
with certain unalienable rights that we
possess
free will which is compromised by sin
for which reason
we must constrain our base passions and
those of the government
too if we dismantle
deconstruct that's the popular word if
we deconstruct
this culture and if we reject that
religion we will not consequently
be made free we will not be liberated on
the contrary
we will forfeit our freedom and our
american way of life
we will be subsumed into the cult of
secular progressivism
with its own rituals and its own
political order
and its own high priests
the enforcers of this creeping state
religion have granted us a reprieve
for now at least in florida basically
just in florida
we can speak for now we can gather for
now we can organize for now
we can articulate a substantive moral
vision
and then we can summon the courage to
assert that vision in politics
or we can surrender to the fouches of
the world
and muzzle ourselves forever the choice
is ours for now thank you very much
very kind of you thank you so much
we will now begin our q a portion of the
event today
so if you would like to ask a question
we just ask that you
go through the center aisle and go
toward the back and the ushers will line
you up
and please just ask one question so
there are no follow-up questions
and um i believe that that is it
so oh and i will hold the microphone for
you so
so no stealing that microphone i know
it's valuable it's a nice microphone
hi mr knowles leftists claim to follow
scientific arguments all the time
when in fact they do not follow science
what effective means can conservatives
use to counter their arguments
since in reality science is on our side
but the media refuses to cover it
yes science is on our side and science
is a creation of christianity
and even even in the modern sense of
material inquiry
science in the broader sense of course
is not confined to material inquiry
it's con it expands all the way to all
of knowledge and i think this is what we
have to focus on
a lot of conservatives are tempted to
say no you know
you man you're not a woman because i can
look at your chromosomes or something
else like
you know and that because of this
physical empirical observation
that's how i know that this is true but
i think that's a fool's errand because
we might win that minor disagreement and
they probably won't even concede that to
us but we'll have given them the premise
that the only legitimate basis for
political discussion is science which is
simply not the case then then we're
really just playing on their grounds
because science
is the handmaiden of philosophy and
philosophy is the handmaiden of theology
so i would not accept their premises i
think that is how the left has advanced
extraordinarily effectively over the
past several decades
and i would really get down to basics
you know if they start arguing with you
over transgenderism or something i would
i would start explaining the hylomorphic
nature of the human soul and
body you know i would really take it out
of their comfort zone because
we are living in a world that they
dominate right now the the liberal
establishment
controls those institutions and they
control the discourse
so i think any way that you can crack
out of that is going to be much more
successful
than just trying to win a little tit for
tat on their own playing field
hey michael knowles so when you're
talking about
the standards of the right and the left
uh it just seems like
in my perspective there's like an
incommensurability between those
standards so how do we even begin
dialogue when there's
exist and then commensurability right
like between those two standards
it just seems like they the systems
themselves are
utterly incompatible and that there is
just like i said they can't be measured
in accordance to the same methods
so like how do we even begin dialogue
how do we even like begin
some kind of path of reconciliation or
some kind of path towards real progress
or is are we just like destined to wait
to the second coming and you know
we win and they lose or they win and we
lose and then we wait for the second
coming and you know it'll get
get kind of tough in the meantime but
then then we'll have a happy ending
i don't think that there is any
reconciling culture and anti-culture
you know because it's it's not merely
that the left is advocating
some other substantive serious standard
they're advocating an anti-standard the
whole point is to destroy the
traditional culture
this is not some conspiracy theory this
is uh
in the writings of karl marx it's in the
writings of antonio gramsci it's in the
writings of the frankfurt school and
later on and
the new left you see it in their
writings today
they want to destroy it's very easy to
destroy it's very hard to build
if they were trying to build something
else
if they if they had a really
constructive vision of politics
then we could try to reconcile our
vision with their vision and hopefully
we'd get like 99 percent they get one
percent but that's coming together in
kumbaya
but it isn't that when when
the battle is between civilization and
the destruction of civilization
you don't want to meet in the middle
what's the middle of that you know ruins
that's a tribal village somewhere i
don't think that we we want to do that
you know it the way you see this
expressed in
regular day-to-day life is that
republicans and democrats used to
disagree
the left and the right used to disagree
but we both waved the american flag
we were both rooting for our country we
both loved our fellow countrymen
that is simply not the case anymore the
american flag is a symbol of the right
and burning the american flag is a
symbol of the left and it's what they
did for much of 2020
and cheered on by the way by prominent
members of that party
so there's there is no reconciliation
there there we
simply have to win but but conservatives
don't want to win
because conservatives are cowards so
they they want to make
all of these very abstract formal
arguments
that basically grant the left's premise
that secular progressivism is a neutral
playing field
but we don't want to actually say
anything so we talk about we need the
right to free speech
absolute free speech but we never have
anything to say
well the right to free speech doesn't
mean anything if you don't have anything
to say so i think that we need to
try to win i think republicans and
conservatives did a great job of
losing with dignity for a long time i
don't think they have very much dignity
doing it either by the way
but i would like to win i'd like to win
with dignity but i'd just like to win
and this might make our friends
uncomfortable but
this is a strategy that the left has
exercised to great avail
and i don't think that we need to pursue
that strategy through immorality as the
left often has
i think we can through great justice
pursue that strategy
but ultimately we've got to win
hey there um big fan so i have a
slightly catholic question if that's
okay
leia as long as it's not a thoroughly
catholic no it's likely it's like a
slight little smidge okay so
you know we're here to catholic school
and kind of thinking about the nature of
catholic education
where do you see the role of a catholic
college at catholic university
in the conservative movement um you know
should we be sending our best and
brightest here
should we be sending them to to an ivy
league school i know you went to some
obscure ivy league school yeah
i can't i don't know how to say the name
but um and i guess twofold question what
do you see the role of
catholic education this conservative
movement and maybe if you had to do it
over again would you attend
a catholic college would you would you
go back to yale to harvard a place like
that or what are your thoughts on on
that
when i graduated from yale i think it
was at the it was at the very beginning
of it totally collapsing
and i mean within a year or two of my
graduation you had the screaming girl
shrieking at her professor
about how yale is not an intellectual
place which unfortunately may have been
a self-fulfilling prophecy
and they coddled the girl and so that
that's really sad while i was there it
was cracking but it
wasn't quite there yet um i would have
had a much better education had i
had i gotten a catholic education had i
gone to a place that really
cared about these things now i don't
mean to diss my alma mater i have great
great love and respect for my alma mater
even if my
alma mater might not love me as much
anymore
because one of the great advantages to
being at a place
everyone talks about you should go to an
ivy league school so you can get a good
banking job
i never did that i probably should have
but i never did that
but i think the great advantage if
you're a conservative or a
christian is if you are at one of these
schools you are constantly going to be
told that you're a vicious file awful
terrible stupid dunce nazi
and so you're gonna have to learn how to
defend
your views and you might discard some
views and you might go deeper on other
views and so
you know i came out of that place i went
into that place a
moderate politically atheist and i came
out
on the road to christianity and rather
conservative slightly to the right of
attila the hun
but but catholic education
is is the coherent education
there there have been derivations of
this yale began as a seminary and yale
still is a seminary by the way
it was a seminary for congregationalism
sort of protestantism in america now
it's a
seminary for progressivism but it just
doesn't quite make as much sense you see
this in the curriculum the curriculum
now is basically
take whatever class interests you and
that'll be totally fine
but a proper curriculum would be in a
university where everything partakes
of when it speak you know what you're
learning in this class speaks to what
you're learning in this class what
you're learning here speaks to what
you're learning here
so i would recommend that people do that
i'm so
shocked by this place i've got to tell
you ave maria it's really great i
i need a school for my kid in about 18
years and this is like top of the list
right now
this or uh franciscan of steubenville
those are the two leaders
so i just wanted to see what kind of a
reaction
so i i do and i do think by the way
that's going to be the future because
you joke about this disreputable school
in new haven called yale
i do think frankly the cachet of these
great
once great universities yale harvard
these places i think it's really
diminishing by the minute
basically because people know that it's
a credential that means you've got a
good sat score and you were probably
president of your high school class
but it doesn't necessarily mean that you
got a proper coherent education while
you were there
and so i i think that the the growth of
catholic education at the lower level
and at the higher level here
of america is a great example shows you
where where the
future of education is in the country i
think that's a good thing
hi since the title of the lecture is
jesus socialist i got a
question about the church standing in
your point of view so
in your opinion to what extent should
the church talk about economical and
social policies
and where is the line of division
between breaching the
trans-politicalness of christianity
by focusing maybe too much on politics
rather than dogma
and standing up against moral evil in
the political sphere and does the church
talk enough about
the social matters in your opinion the
church
both does not talk about the matters
enough when it should
and i think it talks much too much about
matters that
perhaps it shouldn't what i mean by that
is pope leo the 13th
was a great guy he didn't mince words
about socialism
called it a pest a confederacy a wicked
confederacy
that sought to steal the very gospel
itself saint pius the tenth
was not reticent on socialism blessed
pius ix
even john xxiii who was relatively a
more liberal pope
said that no catholic could ascribe even
to a moderate form of socialism
now look where we are today where people
try to make our lord into some
hippie bolshevik or something it's
ridiculous it makes no sense
so i think the church should speak
clearly on those matters and
it doesn't and you know there's there's
always there's perpetually through the
history of the church been a problem
with
prelates uh leaning in toward a little
bit of worldliness
uh but i think the church has a proper
role in matters of this world
and ought to assert her moral authority
with
with divine protection and and guidance
so my answer is yes and no how's that
for an answer i just
my answer is it should do do more of the
good talking and less of the
counterproductive talking
hello sir my name is rafael antonio riva
i'm a half filipino half cuban first
generation american who grew up in china
i'm a communications major at the school
and have a specialty in connecting with
others
establishing honest relationships and
spreading messages what can i do for an
internship please
oh look obviously we don't care about
your academic background at all because
we just talked about how colleges are
fake
and other other than ave maria and
obviously we eschew identity politics we
don't look i don't get into that okay i
don't see race
except for cuban cuban is very good that
will work out very well at the daily
wire
now obviously we would never we would
never raise a camera there's a camera
we would never accept any sort of bribes
if anybody's trying to get a job at the
daily wire
but if your native countries uh crop
were to find its way into my suitcase
you know
with maybe a lighter and a cutter maybe
we could talk very good question and
i'll have to think more seriously about
it
thank you for being here mr knowles uh
big fan uh
i'm a conservative catholic myself and i
have a question there's another
conservative catholic influencer online
his name is nick fuentes
and i know i know you've had your
differences but i've seen there's a lot
of discussion online about
whether you two would possibly be open
to having a debate
about the things that you disagree on
what are your thoughts on that
i love having debates with people on
things that i disagree on and
not just with people on the far left i
love having debates with people
on the far right and i even probably
most of all i enjoy having debates
with people on the squishy right that's
my my favorite
the issue with this fellow that you've
mentioned that i i think
really bugs me is is not so much uh even
the the matter of
having a debate with someone you
disagree with it's that i feel that he's
acting in bad faith
and the reason for that is i i was doing
a photo line the first time i guess the
only time i ever met him
and i did a photo line and i did photos
with hundreds of people
and then he kind of came up at the end
and he was saying oh michael i'm a big
fan of yours and oh you know
you're so great and could i please get a
photo and i said okay that's fine
and so i take a photo could you put your
thumbs up please say okay sure whatever
you know i do this with people
we take this photo and he immediately
puts it on the internet and implies that
we've
had this great accord and we all agree
with one another and i hold his views
and it was just obviously he was trying
to troll me as somebody tells me he's
not a big fan of my work
and so i feel that his interaction was
very much in bad faith
i i am perfectly happy to take
ideas seriously obviously i'm happy to
take ideas seriously on the cultural
and social right i just gave a 25-minute
speech about it
but but i i don't see any reason to
debate with somebody who's who is acting
in bad
faith and it's actually i think more of
an impulse of the
libertarian right to say you know in the
free marketplace of ideas we're just
gonna
always hash out everything no i not only
do i not think it's
productive to debate with people who are
who are behaving in bad faith but i
think it's actually pretty
counterproductive
so you know i'm i keep an open mind
about everything but i don't see any
reason to
engage in what i think is something that
is not sincere or genuine
hey mr knowles first i i'm sure i speak
for everyone i say i'm a huge fan it's
an honor to be able to speak to you and
to ask you a question
especially as someone from a communist
nation originally it's called new jersey
so i have a lot of friends back home who
are very liberal
they're members of lgbtq plus
they have a lot of strong sympathies we
get into a lot of arguments but they
care about me very deeply and i care
about them
now one of the most interesting things
to me is when we look at the state of
america today
we use this win-lose terminology we use
labels um almost as much as they do
in fact the fact that i'm even saying
they is an indicator of that
and the place i've most noticed as a
catholic is within the catholic church
there seems to be a lack of leadership
and more importantly it seems that a lot
of catholics are now taking their
identities instead of
under the cross they're taking with
their political party so you have
conservative catholics who are
conservative first their
their faith informs their politics we're
liberal catholics who don't really
understand their faith all that well and
they're not helped by the political
situation
what is our role especially if when
we're acknowledging these people
um my friends for example who are very
hurt they're very damaged especially
those who are act like
promiscuous lifestyles where they're
just trying to find some kind of
completion
you know and they'll often turn to me
and say like what do you do like dude
why do you hate me
and i'm like why do you hate me like why
do you assume that i hate you it's it's
fascinating to me how much
politics gets set aside we start to talk
about people what can we as
catholics and and those with
conservative like
old-school philosophical values that
have meaning what can we do to
engage that side of mercy which so often
gets overlooked
or at least i feel by conservative
catholics well you've given the answer
yourself which is in these personal
interactions you know ours is a rather
personal faith uh eucharistic adoration
is a rather per i mean receiving the
blessed sacrament itself is a rather
personal experience
when you're in the confessional that's a
rather personal experience and it's an
incarnational one
your point on on people putting their
political views first is well taken
now as i hope i've shown a little bit in
this speech tonight the line between
politics and culture and religion
is a little bit blurry i think we've we
kid ourselves when we say they're
totally separable things i don't think
that's true we're just talking about the
truth right we all just want the good
the true and the beautiful
and so we try to compartmentalize and
say well i'm talking about science and
i'm talking about politics and i'm
talking about culture but
really we're ultimately talking about
the same thing these transcendentals
have something to do with one another
but you know all of that is well and
good to think about and to think about
our own identities but we have to do it
we have to act it and of course we have
to
to guide ourselves toward the cross
you know a a sane civilization
identifies itself with the i
am right moses asks god who shall i say
you are i
say i am that i am christ says before
abraham was
i am so a civilization that identifies
itself with the i am
knows who it is and when you divorce
yourself from the i am you are left with
a pathetic question
which is who am i and we try on all
sorts of different identities and we
have ever multiplying greek grievance
groups
and the alphabet thing it goes now it's
at like 700 letters
and the racial groups they make a new
racial group every day and it's really
pathetic because ultimately these
these physical things these sensuous
things are are not going to
to satisfy one's longings because
ultimately we are religious beings
and and when we don't satisfy our
religious
longings with true religion we'll just
come up with a bunch of kooky false
religions
which is why people are now embracing
transgender gnosticism and
crystals and horoscopes and things like
that uh so
i i would i would make it rather
personal and
uh i've noticed this thing
from my liberal friends in new york or
la or from college every all these
people were liberals
and they all liked me well enough when i
would see them all the time and we'd
hang out and go to parties and
they were cool that they hated all the
conservatives i agreed with but they
liked me
they couldn't really make any sense of
it and for some people the longer i go
without seeing them personally
then they don't like me anymore and i'm
sure this is true of a great many people
in this room
because when you're out of sight you're
out of mind it's easier to create a
caricature of that person hunter biden
just came out with a memoir
i don't intend to read it but i have
read excerpts of it hunter biden has
read
has lived rather about as rotten a life
as you can lead
a truly rotten miserable life born with
every advantage
went through some hardship we all go
through a hardship but he really had
every advantage and he just burned all
of it on nothing
and what strikes me about reading these
passages from hunter biden's memoir is
you kind of feel bad for the guy you
kind of feel bad for him because he's
sick
you know and he's because he's indulged
his basest passions at every chance he
gets
he hasn't cultivated his discipline or
his intellect or his will
and so it's this kind of vicious cycle
like a heroin addict right you know you
make the free choice to shoot up hero i
mean i guess in his case that's
literally what happened
and but you you make the choice right
you make the choice to indulge this
passion for some drug
and you have you basically have a graph
of your grasp of your freedom
but then the more you do it the less
freedom you have and then ultimately
you'll do anything
just to get another hit as long as
you've got a couple bucks in your pocket
in the constellation of philosophy
boethius describes this well he says
that prosecutors
should be they're like therapists
they're like doctors you know they're
trying to help you
even in giving you punishment they are
trying to help you because criminals are
sick people
who have their free will compromised and
who are given into all these awful sins
and so i i just think if even someone is
as odious as hunter biden could could be
sympathetic i suppose we all are because
they are before the grace of god go i
alright we're all
all man is sinned and falled and
shortened of the glory of god
and if we i think engage in that very
personal
manner not only will we be able to reach
these friends that we want to reach
but you know maybe more importantly for
this issue they'll be able to reach us
and they'll realize that we're not a
bunch of hitlerian
nazi fascist white supremacist this is
thattist sort of people and i think that
could open their minds quite quite a bit
more too
all right so some conservatives on
social media or at least the ones that
haven't been canceled yet
are deeming what's going on in our
country as a socialist onslaught and our
country is
incredibly currently politically
polarized people with old-school
conservative or liberal values are a lot
more
quote middle of the road you could say
now with these extreme ideologies taking
over on both sides
on the path that we seem to be on as a
nation where do you realistically see
this country in 20 to 30 years
well i see fire i see brimstone i see
rubble
i see ruins the point you've hit on is
the key here
people whose views used to seem pretty
left-wing
now seem kind of right-wing and people
who had perfectly ordinary conservative
views i don't wave the american flag
they are neo-nazi fascists the
window of acceptable speech has shifted
radically to the left if you object to
shooting kids full of cross-sex hormones
you're on the fringes at this point of
the right
the reason for that is that the the
rights
defense strategy here has failed
what the right has viewed this battle as
is a battle between free speech and
censorship and we're going to stand for
free speech darn in any view holds
and not you sensorious people all
civilizations have certain speech that's
off limits
all civilizations have taboos this is
natural this is not going to change you
can say well i read a novel
by ein rand where you know in the future
this utopia is going to exist
you're right it's in the future because
it's not going to happen it's never
happened anywhere in human history
we need to grapple with those standards
we need to say yes some things are off
limits sure if you show up to work with
a swastika armband
and you start yelling zig heil at the
water cooler it's not cancel culture
when you
lose your job it's not it's perfectly
right to cancel you
the same thing if you have a hammer and
sickle on your arm in my view
we we need to in bill buckley's words he
said we need to be
epistemological optimists we need to
recognize some things really are settled
some things really are better than other
things some things really are truer than
other things and we need to have the
courage to articulate what that vision
is and we need to take that window right
now which has shifted all the way to the
left
because we've just given in to them
every step of the way even when we
thought we were fighting them we were
giving in to them because we abandoned
our standards
and we need to reassert those standards
and move it right on back
to the right and the all that's lacking
right now is courage i think we kind of
have the vision there are plenty of
people who are talking about these
things
but the bulk of republicans and
certainly republican office holders
just don't want to do it i have said
before i hope president trump lives a
long life
and i hope that when he goes to his
eternal reward he donates his body to
science
and his spine to the gop
courage
courage is a virtue courage is the
prerequisite for all the other virtues
so i think
the way to do it is pretty clear i
outline it actually in my book
speechless which is coming up right now
and you can pre-order it i think the
path the path is clear enough
just do everything i say and then it'll
be fine uh the path i think is clear
enough
what's lacking is courage will we get
that courage i hope so
but i don't know i wouldn't bet the farm
on it i i think that that's going to be
the real challenges not even
articulating the substantive vision it's
growing the various biological
appendages that are very much in
the public conversation now regarding
transgenderism and
we need to summon those sort of genital
features
and uh actually assert a positive agenda
thanks for your time um so my question
is about
your history of the conservative
movement it seems to me that you sound a
little bit more like el brand bozell
than
um william f buckley um i like doing the
reading well they're
they're uh relatives right i mean they
were best friends at the ypu
um i'm sure i'm sure you had a good time
anyway so my question is you know bozell
ultimately came to the point that he
believed that
to be an authentically catholic
politician you had to be sort of
anti-american
yeah and so why do you think he's wrong
and why do you think buckley is a more
sure foundation for catholic politics or
christian politics
really i i'm not saying that in the
ideal perfect
world bill buckley is 100 the perfect
political figure that ever lived i
really i admire the guy immensely but
bill buckley wouldn't say that either by
the way right he wouldn't say i'm the be
all and end all
he was the most successful and he was
for a reason and he was quite catholic
by the way and i think that he
like his friend ronald reagan have
suffered greatly from being made into an
ism
you know i think that reaganism and
buckley-ism
are a whole lot squishier than the
actual men ronald reagan and bill
buckley a whole lot squishier
um but but inasmuch as buckley might
have a
disagreement with brent bozell or
you know that an american conservative
might have a disagreement with i don't
know a
continental catholic integralist or
something like that
i suppose where i want to begin is not
in the abstract realm i don't
i don't treat politics as a sort of
rationalist exercise
where i think goodness gracious you know
if the maryland colony had really worked
out you know and the catholics had stuck
around and maybe they would have spread
out we could have gotten pennsylvania we
could have gotten new york
this would have been a catholic country
darn it i think catholic ideas
by by the nature of our civilization
catholic ideas
directed the development of the united
states but i want to begin
with real practical stuff i want to go
back
to a guy who was like almost a catholic
he wasn't quite a catholic edmund burke
i want to go back to prudence
which you're not even allowed to say the
word prudence in politics anymore
everything's got to be rational and
scientific
prudence is pretty good i want to go
back to tested tried and true things
that have actually
existed i want to go back to the flesh
and blood
and brick and mortar traditions of of
our republic
the fourth of july is not just about
reciting the declaration of independence
i wouldn't like it if it were the fourth
of july is also about
you honor the founding fathers and you
eat hot dogs and you drink beer and you
watch fireworks that's not a rationalist
undertaking
that is part of the real lived
experience if you will
of of the american political life
and so if if it would be better to get
back to a more traditional conservatism
as perhaps uh brent bozell would have
liked i think the way to do it
is not to say okay pause all that stuff
we've been doing for a few hundred years
get rid of it
and now we're going to import i don't
know joseph demester or something right
now that's how we're going to begin
the new catholic regime in america i
think you would do that gradually
evolution not revolution as as i think
people are doing right now it is no
coincidence on
the catholicity of your question it's no
coincidence that
perhaps the the all of the most
prominent conservatives in american
history have been catholic
isn't that weird we're told that this is
a protestant nation and yet even even of
just the last hundred years
russell kirk bill buckley phyllis
schlafly the list goes on
and on and on well why is that well
perhaps because
of all of these strains of christianity
and political thought in the west
catholicism just goes back the furthest
doesn't it it's
it's got the most durability and hillary
bellock had a good line he said
that he's i am bound by my faith to hold
the catholic church to be a divine
institution
but for people who doubt that here's
some proof
no other organization run with such
navish imbecility would have lasted a
fortnight
this is a really durable institution and
these ideas are really durable and
they've been tried for a long time and
so
i'm i'm always for a greater
approaching of the good the true and the
beautiful and i don't make an idol even
out of the greatest men who helped build
our nation
but i i wouldn't go about it with some
crazy revolution i just don't think it
would work
very good question
this next question will be the last
question of the night no
no thank you so much for being here mr
knowles it's a real honor to
to be here and hear your talk my
question is about uh you talk a lot
about objective truth
and kind of the need to revitalize
objective truth and use it to revitalize
the american ideal
um but i'm wondering on the other hand
you have
the ideals of the founding and the
philosophy of the founding
that there is no sum bonum there is no
highest
end or objective end for man to achieve
and of course they had their reasons for
having this idea and
it of course leaves room for us to
pursue excellence and pursue the
catholic faith
within uh this regime but i'm wondering
how you can reconcile those ideas of
of objective truth and then this element
of the founding
because they do seem a little
contradictory it's an
excellent question the way that i do
this is i don't make idols out of
even the founding fathers i think they
would be
among the first people to admit that
they were imperfect
some of them were more arrogant than
others but but i think most of them
would admit that they were imperfect and
they were seeing things
imperfectly and so i i don't make an
idol out of
the pilgrims on the mayflower and i
don't make an idol out of
1776 and i don't make an idol out of
1860 in 1865 and i don't make an idol
out of 1980 for that matter
um the the evolution of political
thought
in the united states bears some
historical
notice namely we are now told that in
the name of liberalism we cannot
ever speak of religion in public and
there's no way to know anything about
god or anything like that and
we've got to tolerate all sorts of views
and
have academic freedom which has never
existed anywhere and you know
just say anything we want to say and
have no standards at all john locke who
greatly influenced the american founding
famously said in his letter concerning
toleration that we need to tolerate
everybody
except atheists no toleration for
atheists
and he made it a very good argument john
milton who wrote the areopagitica
of greatest defense most robust defense
of free speech in the english language
said we need free speech for everybody
except catholics and frankly i
understand his argument
and i think if he could hear this what
we're saying tonight he would absolutely
shut this down they'd pull the feed
but but they made they made arguments
given the nature of that regime
and i just don't think that the american
regime i don't think we're stuck in 2021
as the progressive sort of wish that we
were they say oh michael you hold a view
from
1992 that's so outdated you know where
get with the current year but likewise
as some conservatives do i don't think
that we're stuck in 1776
i think the tradition extends further
back and i think it has moved forward
and i think we've in some ways perhaps
corrected
some of the ideas that maybe weren't
quite so right and
it is simply a matter of logic that if
anything
is better than anything else then there
is a greatest
thing there is a sumum bonum
as you say in latin and i think that
people are
waking up to that and i think in much of
the political conversation that's
happening on the right now
people are recognizing the importance of
the good
to all regimes ev everywhere for all of
human history
and certainly to our regime so i i hold
out hope that uh
we can take the best of the past and uh
by the
the light of our reason and with the
guiding help of providence
be able to even perhaps hope for a
better future maybe that's too rosy a
way to end i
you know usually it's fire and brimstone
and pessimism and all this sorts
a priest friend of mine famously says
that
the difference between a scottish
optimist and a scottish pessimist is
that a scottish
pessimist says things can't get any
worse and a scottish optimist says oh
yes they can
and i think conservatives you know kind
of fall into this a lot too
but your question raises a very
important
uh important point which is right now i
see good things happening on the right
and i see extraordinarily intelligent
young people
who are waking up and recognizing that
the ossified ridiculous platitude
bumper sticker slogans that we have been
fed
as a stand-in for the conservative
tradition over the last 15 20 years
are just ridiculous they don't stand up
to anything
and i think that's something that will
cause us a little bit of
difficulty in the short term because
there's going to be some political
ranker
but ultimately i think that will be a
great hope for our country
and for our civilization and hopefully
we can all lift our eyes up and see
that ultimate good excellent question
thank you so much
for being here such a pleasure to be
with you all
thank you very much thank you thank you
so much
you